happening right now we're celebrating
our asian american community this is
asian american pacific islander month
aapi nevada rise academy is hosting its
annual hawaiian festival to mark the
occasion justin brecht is the executive
director at nevada rise academy he says
the charter school has a very diverse
student population so they hold a lot of
festivals like this all year round they
even do it during black history month
hispanic heritage month he says the goal
is to celebrate all of our different
cultures and bring the community
together
we have a variety of activities to
celebrate different parts of asia so we
have
henna tattoos a color run we have a
filipino street games activity center
carp kites from japan
a yoga station a meditation station out
front
pretty cool stuff a lot of cool food
trucks there too festival ends in about
a couple hours two o'clock today it is
open to you it is free but of course
there's a cost if you're going to use
those food trucks a lot of things
happening around the valley for aapi
month